Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
soy lluis Muñoz y en esta edición
hablamos con uriol junqueras ex
vicepresidente de Cataluña Y actualmente
presidente del partido político esquerra
republicana de Cataluña actualmente en
el gobierno de la región catalana Muchas
gracias uriol por estar en la entrevista
de France 24 un placer estar aquí con
vosotros estamos en la universidad de
América acá en Bogotá usted acaba de dar
una charla sobre la relación entre
Cataluña y América Latina sobre todo en
términos democráticos Cuál es nos parece
que hay algunos elementos comunes en las
democracias occidentales en este momento
Y es que en algunas ocasiones las
pulsiones la voluntad democrática la
voluntad de transformación democrática
encuentra trabas en aquellos que han
ejercido el poder de manera habitual de
manera tradicional
entre los poderosos de toda la vida y
que una parte de estas trabas de estas
palos en las ruedas de la voluntad
democrática se expresan a veces a veces
a través de algunos de una parte de
algunos sistemas judiciales y que esto
explica Porque algunos candidatos
electos algunos presidentes
de República algunos candidatos
presidenciales han sido apartados de sus
actividades de la política de sus
funciones por parte de decisiones de
carácter judicial
esto también ha sucedido en Cataluña
donde una mayoría democrática una amplia
mayoría democrática a expresada en con
una mayoría absoluta en el parlamento a
que apoya Un gobierno convoca y organiza
un referéndum gana este referéndum y la
respuesta de una parte de la judicatura
es la cárcel el exilio a la persecución
económi la inhabilitación la prohibición
de hacer vida política para muchos de
los responsables Entonces tenemos la
sensación de que en muchos casos cuando
determinados sectores no tienen la
capacidad de ganar en las urnas intentan
imponer su voluntad contra las urnas
usted como bien hablaba ha estado casi
cuatro años en prisión y este es su
primer viaje fuera de Europa después de
ese paso por prisión en una gira por
Colombia chile y Argentina
porque ha escogido estos países donde
también hay un sentimiento de unidad
nacional En el que no existen fisuras
bueno es que es perfectamente compatible
querer la independencia de Cataluña creo
que Cataluña se constituya en una nueva
República en el ámbito de la Unión
Europea es perfectamente compatible con
el hecho de ser profundamente
federalistas en términos europeos
evidente que nosotros somos
independentistas respecto al de España
pero respecto a Europa Somos unos
federalistas convencidos y defendemos
una Europa más unida con unas
instituciones comunes más fuertes el
parlamento europeo la comisión europea
con un parlamento europeo que tenga más
capacidad legislativa que tengan más
capacidad de control sobre el poder
ejecutivo que tenga una relación Más
directa con los selectores y que todo
ello es perfectamente compatible con la
defensa de un modelo de crecimiento
económico y de estado del bienestar de
equidad de Justicia
no solo en Europa sino en el conjunto
del mundo y singularmente también en
América Latina en donde en este momento
vivimos
la esperanza de movimientos que tienen
la voluntad de transformar la realidad
en positivo que tienen la voluntad de
construir sociedades más justas porque
sólo las sociedades más justas son
capaces de tener y de generar un
crecimiento económico sostenido y
disponible en este momento en la
actualidad catalana y española se está
hablando mucho de aquel delito de
sedición por el que la mitad del
gobierno tuvo que ingresar en prisión el
gobierno de Cataluña
usted ha definido que esa retirada del
delito es edición es un éxito para
Cataluña es un éxito para la democracia
es un éxito para que responde a las a la
posicionamiento del working Group de
detenciones arbitrarias en Naciones
Unidas que lo que pedía era la libertad
de los presos políticos en España y los
presos políticos catalanes que lo que
pedía era el retorno de los exiliados
que lo que pedía es la plenitud del
ejercicio de nuestros derechos Como
cargos electos
de los derechos de nuestros selectores
Pero también es un éxito para la
asamblea parlamentaria del Consejo de
Europa que votó exactamente el mismo
sentido también es un éxito para el
comité de derechos humanos de Naciones
Unidas que se posicionó exactamente en
el mismo sentido que defendemos nosotros
y por lo tanto estamos convencidos que
es un éxito no no para nosotros ni
siquiera tan solo para Cataluña sino que
es un éxito para la democracia y para
todos aquellos organismos
internacionales que se han posicionado
claramente contra la represión y que se
han posicionado claramente a favor de
ejercicios de derechos tan fundamentales
Como por ejemplo el derecho al voto Y
esto es parte de unas conversaciones
unas negociaciones con el gobierno de
España al que es que republicana ha
apoyado en esta legislatura son mejores
las relaciones con Madrid en este
momento
pues son unas relaciones siempre
complejas porque tenemos aspiraciones
muy muy diferenciadas nosotros aspiramos
a una República a una democracia más
plena una democracia más profunda a una
sociedad más justa a una sociedad con
mayor capacidad de generar riqueza y de
distribuir riqueza de crecimiento
económico y tenemos la convicción de que
esto es muy difícil en el marco de un
estado español que está muy alejado
desde nuestro punto de vista de los
estándares democráticos internacionales
porque condena a prisión a personas que
lo único que han hecho
es facilitar el derecho al voto de sus
ciudadanos Y esta es una opinión que no
solo es nuestra sino que también es una
opinión de una parte relevante de la
magistratura cuando hay
magistrados del tribunal constitucional
que afirman que ninguno de los hechos
que se nos imputan es constitutivo de
delito alguno recogido en el código
penal Y si esta es la opinión de
diversos magistrados a lo que resulta
inexplicable es que alguien se haga
condenado a 13 años de cárcel por algo
que no está recogido en el código penal
usted llegó a la dirección de esquerra
republicana de Cataluña hace 11 años
estaba el partido un poco en caída libre
ahora mismo es el partido de gobierno en
Cataluña hablando un poco de cómo es la
sociedad catalana ahora vemos como en
Europa crece la ultraderecha lo hemos
visto en Italia en España también hay
sondeos que indican que las elecciones
2023 podría aumentar ese tipo de Voto
pero Cataluña se mantiene un poco al
margen por qué
porque creo que somos una sociedad
profundamente democrática con unas
aspiraciones democráticas muy muy
intensas porque creo que somos una
sociedad muy inclusiva es que
republicana de Cataluña es un partido
que que se honra de tener entre sus
cargos electos a una diputada en el
congreso español que es brasileña a una
senadora que es uruguaya a un senador
que es de la India a una diputada en el
parlamento de Cataluña que es
ecuatoriana A una diputada y a un
diputado en el parlamento de Cataluña
que son de origen marroquí y por lo
tanto nos parece que nuestro partido es
un claro ejemplo de esta voluntad de
construir una sociedad inclusiva una
sociedad integradora una sociedad grande
de derechos para todos los ciudadanos
con independencia del lugar donde hayan
nacido o con independencia de sus
creencias religiosas o con independencia
de Muchas de sus posibles preferencias y
muchos ámbitos posibles y estamos
convencidos de que solo sociedades de
este tipo sociedades que garanticen la
inclusividad a la la igualdad de
oportunidades la plenitud de los
Derechos son sociedades que estarán en
condiciones de seguir creciendo también
en términos económicos y también en
términos de derechos sociales en el
futuro volviendo brevemente a que el
octubre 2017 aquel referendo hay muchas
voces también que se han mostrado desde
el independentismo un tanto engañadas
con lo que siguió y con no haber podido
conseguir la independencia
solo hay un camino para construir una
República en la Europa actual y es el
camino democrático y es el camino de ser
más para ser más fuertes en términos
democráticos y es el camino de obtener
mejores resultados electorales y es el
camino de tener mayor representación
institucional No solo en el gobierno de
Cataluña que en este momento es un
gobierno de esquer republicana sino
también en todas las cámaras
parlamentarias donde Nuestra fuerza es
decisiva pero también en el ámbito
municipal en el ámbito supramunicipal
también en el parlamento europeo por lo
tanto sería un camino que ser de la
democracia y de la fuerza democrática y
el camino también
delimitar el uso de las herramientas
antidemocráticas que ha utilizado una
parte de los aparatos del estado en
contra de la democracia y en contra del
ejercicio de derecho a voto de los
ciudadanos Y esta es nuestra propuesta y
estamos convencidos que no hay ninguna
propuesta alternativa y por esta razón
siempre a todos los demócratas a
compartir con nosotros a esta voluntad
legítima de construir una nueva
república más libre más justa del mismo
modo que nosotros expresamos siempre
nuestras solidaridad hacia todos los
proyectos de carácter democrático de
carácter inclusivo con voluntad de
Justicia con voluntad de crecimiento con
voluntad de bienestar de los ciudadanos
en todas partes del mundo y en este caso
singularmente en toda América Latina ya
hemos visto con la Guerra de Ucrania que
los organismos internacionales han dado
mucho apoyo en la soberanía de los
estados eso puede ser un escollo también
con el apoyo que podría recibir el
estado español
la razón de estado y la idea de estado
nacional es una una idea y una razón que
no deberían y que no deben hacer un
obstáculo para los derechos humanos y
para los derechos fundamentales y
estamos convencidos que cualquier
democracia debe respirar a que su
estatalidad No seas no solo sea
compatible con la plenitud de los
Derechos Humanos que incluye Obviamente
el derecho al voto sino que son dos
elementos que deberían ser siempre
inseparables es decir el estado los
estados occidentales deben ser grandes
de los derechos humanos y los Derechos
Humanos deben ser la manera en que los
ciudadanos se expresan para definir el
papel de sus estados y por lo tanto
nosotros entendemos perfectamente a el
papel de los países occidentales en este
momento y al mismo tiempo no podemos
dejar de hacer un llamamiento a eterno
constante y universal a la defensa de
los derechos fundamentales y de los
Derechos
Humanos a los derechos universales y ya
para acabar los sondeos de opinión
pública aún mantienen que hay más de un
40% de apoyo a la independencia usted ha
sido profesor de historia y se dice que
la historia se repite eso significa que
no va a ser posible esa Independencia es
que los partidos independentistas
consiguen siempre la mayoría absoluta en
el parlamento de Cataluña y hay un
partido independentista que es el
nuestro que gana todas las elecciones y
obtiene los mejores resultados en las
elecciones españolas en las elecciones
al congreso en las elecciones al senado
en las elecciones municipales y por lo
tanto nos parece que el mejor argumento
es el voto de los ciudadanos Y en este
sentido el voto de los ciudadanos es muy
claro y hay un 80% de la sociedad
catalana que según todas las encuestas
defiende el fin de la represión defiende
una negociación sincera y defiende el
derecho al voto de la ciudadanía para
decir el futuro de nuestro país y en
este 80% de la sociedad catalana que se
expresa en este sentido reiteradamente
en todas las encuestas se incluye
también el 73% de los votantes del
partido socialista por lo tanto si
partido socialista o cualquier otro
partido quiere reconciliarse con estos
ochentas por cien de la sociedad
catalana que se expresa en estos
términos
de haber recorrer un largo Camino Aún un
largo camino de respeto a la democracia
y a la voluntad de la ciudadanía Gracias
Uriel por estar en la entrevista de
France 24 ha sido un placer y espero
tener ocasión de reencontrarme con
vosotros en muchas otras ocasiones aquí
en América Latina y muchas gracias a
nuestra audiencia Pueden seguir más
contenidos como este en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]